from bloomberg quick take i'm madison
mills
it's election day and record numbers of
voters are casting their ballots
but it's not just the presidential
election at stake
there are several key senate races that
we're going to be watching
throughout the night let's take a look
at some of those important senate races
seven black candidates are running in
competitive senate races this year
their races could make history
i'm ready to be your senator
[Music]
of the 2000 senators to serve in the u.s
only 10 have been black of the seven
candidates most are in the south and six
are democrats the lone republican
running in michigan one of these
candidates is reverend rafael warnock
from georgia
we say to america witness
the new south and we're ready for change
black candidates across the country are
winning primaries and running in
competitive districts
which could make the next congress a
record-breaking one for black lawmakers
this comes after a summer of protests in
support of the black lives matter
movement
took place in all 50 states making it
the largest set of protests in u.s
history
we have to remember that we are not
simply voting for the president of the
united states as vital as that is
we're voting for senators who are going
to be essential for passing the changes
in law that we need
to make manifest a democracy that we've
only dreamed about
america's lack of black senators is a
pattern even in states with large black
populations
in louisiana the population is 33 black
but the state has never had a black
senator this is one of many reasons
lawmakers are calling this a start
that's nowhere near the finish line
my belief is that this election cycle is
better than
it would have been had we not been
engaged but we are nowhere near where we
should be as an american society that is
premised on the notion of democracy
joining us to discuss these races and
his own
experience on the ballot tonight is
mayor tubbs from stockton california
mayor tubbs how are you doing today
i am good how are you i'm good how does
it feel to be
on the ballot yourself how's the
election going for you today even though
this is my
third general election i think my fifth
or sixth election including primary
it always feels surreal to have your
name on a ballot
um with the presidential candidates of
the united states of america
as someone your neighbors could vote to
help lead the community so i'm always
excited on election day always a little
bit nervous and always
always in awe that despite the issues
this country faces the fact that i'm
able to run for office
and now run as an incumbent shows that
all hope
is not lost and there is a path forward
right and i want to talk more about your
experience as
mayor but first how is voting going in
your district can you talk to me a
little bit about
anything you're seeing at the polls
today has there been any
voter issues or violence that you've
experienced at the polls
no it's been consistent with our
experience particularly these last kind
of six months even with
protests that we haven't called the
national guard in stockton i haven't
issued a curfew in stockton that
we've been able to do democracy right um
and give people space to protest and
today
give folks the ability to vote we have
extremely safe
drive-through kind of voting polling
stations
um where folks are dropping off their
ballots at city halls and
at city hall another location and i
haven't heard any problems or any
incidents of voter suppression in
stockton's i'm proud
again of our community for understanding
that democracy works best or it only
works in fact
when everyone can vote
absolutely and i'm wondering if you can
talk a little bit more about
where you're thinking your district is
going to land not only of course
on your seat uh but also just on the
presidential election as your
as a whole what are you hearing from
voters yeah well i'm hearing from rodris
and i've heard this from
my first month in office with all the
craziness around immigration
um and and taking people away from their
families etc
now folks understand that things will
never be perfect but they expect
progress and professionalism for their
elected leaders
so i know a lot of people are excited
i've seen makeshift bite inherits signs
because i guess
they ran out of the official ones and
folks are really excited
about actually getting this coronavirus
pandemic under control
people are really excited about actually
having a sane
humane and just immigration policy
people are excited about just having
rational and reasonable disagreements
that aren't about whether
one has inherent human dignity or worth
but maybe about different ways of
approaching a share
a commonly recognized problem um so i
know the folks in stockton are excited
we've seen our
absentee ballot return rate i think
we're at 45 50
um before today in terms of all ballots
and i think in 2016 we only had a 60
turnout for the presidential so it's
looking like we're going to shatter that
norm
i'm excited about it and as you kind of
shatter those 2016 numbers it's not just
the presidential election that'll be
impacted right it's also these down the
ballot races that we mentioned earlier
are there any candidates that you're
particularly excited about
not just in california but across the
u.s i've spent a lot of time supporting
candidates throughout this country um
yasamin
is a good friend of mine who's running
for city council in phoenix i think
her election to phoenix arizona will be
incredibly important
my friend jevin hodge is running for
supervisor in maricopa county
i'm one of the most it's like a 50 50
democrats republican county
so it's gonna be a close race but he's
again another young millennial
um who's running for office i'm
incredibly proud of him my good friend
adrian perkins
um a fellow mayor america who's running
for senator
of the great state of louisiana and i'm
looking forward to him advancing to the
runoff
and making a very competitive push to be
the first black senator
in louisiana which i just mentioned on
the top a state that is over 30
african-american and then in stockton my
best friend lang luntau
is running for re-election as a school
board member so i'm looking forward to
his re-election as well
and mayor tubbs we are hearing some
breaking news the associated press is
calling cory booker as the winner
the winner of the senate race in new
jersey he's one of the seven
black candidates running for senate this
election cycle
as we're getting this breaking news and
i'm wondering if you can talk
a bit about the importance of having
politicians who
look like the electorate as we're
heading into this election after a
summer of protests
in support of the black lives matter
movement across all 50 states
what does that representation mean for
voters
yeah and i think it's representation not
just in in rhetoric or appearance but in
a lived experience and policy priorities
because for example we know the attorney
general of kentucky
is a black man who has done nothing
around the death and murder of brianna
taylor although he looks like a black
man
um so that's completely unacceptable so
i think when we talk about
representation
we're talking about people who can
really speak to live experiences and i
know
as the mayor of a city that's only the
first black mayor of stockton the city
that's only 10
black my experiences as a black man have
allowed me to have empathy
for all the communities i represent from
like i don't know what it's like to have
immigrant parents
but there is no i do know what it's like
to have a parent taken away because of
incarceration
um i'm able to relate to my family's
there i don't know what it's like to be
an lgbtq person in this country but i do
know what it's like to feel marginalized
or rendered invisible so i connect with
my lgbt constituents i think in the same
way
it's incumbent on us to have elected
officials who can speak
to the particular experiences because we
know in america not everyone is yet
truly equal
and having folks who know what it's like
to be treated unequal
i would i would argue leads to a better
result in terms of policies that get us
to the end goal
of equality and justice for all
and sticking with that for a bit how has
your
personal experience impacted the way
that you think about and shape policy
for your constituents
oh it is the throw it's the prism
through which i view the world but it's
not like it's not a mode
it's a bridge it allows me to really
empathize and understand other
experiences
but from everything we're doing in
stockton to the violence reduction work
we've seen this
significant decline in homicides and i'm
passionate about that because my cousin
was murdered here in stockton
and i understand that cops alone aren't
going to solve that public health issue
of gun violence
that we have to fight power reading we
have to target the young men
at risk of being victims of perpetrators
of gun crimes with
actual opportunity um the basic income
power we're doing in stockton comes from
growing up with a single mother
and watching her struggle and watching
her work and never seeing her
wait for someone to give her a hangout
never saw her squander money away
never saw her be lazy or dumb
but sahara worked incredibly hard but
still struggle because the structural
issues on our economy and that's why i
was like we're going to do a basic
income despite
at the time when we announced it people
thinking that idea was too radical
or even the work we're doing around
stockton scholars where every single kid
in my largest school district
that's given a four-year two-year trade
school scholarship comes from being the
first one in my family to go to college
and knowing how much it meant for me to
hear people tell me that they saw me
as someone who had a future after high
school someone who was worthy of the
investment
of having their higher education paid
for so absolutely i think my lived
experiences
make me a better elected official
thank you for sharing that mayor tubbs
and something that we're hearing right
now is that there is a bit of
violence in southern california and
we've spoken with some elected officials
throughout the day today who have said
that they
are uh expecting to have higher police
presences
in their cities to account for this
violence do you envision that
leading to uh police brutality in these
cities
uh if this unrest unfolds tonight um
i i would hope not but i think we've
seen
particularly with the protests around
black lives matter
that we have um significant progress to
be made
in terms of how we allow for protests
and etc
but i also would argue that we part of
this is a symptom of the problem that's
on the ballot
which is the current president he has
emboldened white supremacists he has
told his boys
who are proud to stand by and stand
ready or whatever he said
and has really emboldened also some
members of law enforcement to feel like
that they are the judge the jury
executioner um so with that being the
backdrop i hope people
vote i hope people vote for a better
future for us all
and i hope we all understand that even
if there is a little bit of conflict
that's just the end of an era and we're
going to move turn the page
into a united states it's not perfect
but it's actually making progress in a
nation that really understands
the inherent dignity of all human beings
you mentioned the president emboldening
some of these actions and we did hear
the president at his rallies over the
past few days
uh sort of calling on his supporters to
go to the polls and
potentially intimidate voters are you
concerned about that behavior
not only in your district but across the
country
absolutely we have seen voter
suppression
um in real time and not in history books
not just this election but in the
midterms etc and it's completely
unacceptable i remember studying the
civil rights movement thinking
well we are not perfect but at least we
want people to vote in the fact that
there's not just a president
but an entire political party who in
gubernatorial races
and senate races and house races and
local races
stake their claim to legitimacy on
making sure that
people most impacted by policy don't
vote is completely unacceptable and
that's something we're going to have to
address
within the first 100 days of this new
congress that we're going to have to do
something
to make sure that voter suppression just
like white supremacy is a relic we look
at in museums
not a live experience it makes no sense
to call ourselves the world's greatest
democracy
democrats that people rule we don't want
all people to vote
and that just has to change so it's
heartbreaking that's reminder of the
work we have to do
again it has to be priority number one
ensuring free
and fair elections in this country in
perpetuity
as soon as we get a new administration
in new congress then
and looking beyond voter suppression one
issue that may come
from tonight's results is the president
could contest
the election particularly in certain
swing states
um have you thought about how you might
handle that
and have you spoken with any other
mayors or local officials about
what they might do if the election
results are contested
right i mean mayors um community members
aunties and grandmas and fathers and
grandfathers i think that's um
item one on people's minds which is
unfortunate in america in 2020 on
election night this is the conversation
we have to have
but my response has always been
let's make sure that doesn't happen that
there's still time at least on the west
coast to get to the polls so if you're
in colorado if you're in arizona
make sure you go vote get your cousins
to vote get everyone you know to vote
so we don't have to have we don't have
this issue but if if the issue arises we
have to be very clear
and very firm but this is not about a
a crazy white supremacist incompetent
president
this is about our country this is about
our republic this is about democratic
values and norms that this same
conversation was happening in another
country
we would call the u.n to be election
monitors of the same
the things we criticize the deposits and
dictators for
is what's being talked about here in our
country and we won't stand for this so
i'll be the first one
as soon as the election results are
contested to be a very clear voice about
the need to count
every vote including melbourne ballots
about the fact that whoever wins
the popular vote in the electoral
college should be named present
then also fight to abolish the electoral
college so we don't have to keep having
this sort of conversation every four
years
i want to dig into that for a minute
what do you see that fight to abolish
the electoral college look
looking like it's going to be it's a
constitutional amendment
i i've heard or or or something of that
sort so it's going to
take sort of intense organizing in the
house of representatives and the senate
to make it a a something that has to
happen just like we have to the boss to
filibuster i believe
and just like we have to expand the
supreme court and i know for some people
that feels radical
but we live in radical times we have a
group that does not have legitimacy
to be appointing supreme court justices
while the elections going on and has
done so
and we all have to live with the
consequences of those actions and i
understand
the wisdom of our founding fathers was
in creating a document that could be
malleable with times that they weren't
psychics that they can't couldn't see
the future that they gave us a great
framework
but that framework has to be made to fit
in our times and our times demand
a senate that's able to legislate and do
the people's work which is
requiring in the filibuster our times
will mandate an electoral college it
makes no sense
that one party can only win the
presidency not by winning the popular
vote that's just anti-democratic and
that's an archaic form
of election results and voting that was
created when i was considered property
when women couldn't vote it's it's it's
not like it's something that was part of
our modern democratic era and something
that
absolutely should be abolished a lot of
the policies you just mentioned
are big federal uh policies that would
have to be rolled out i'm curious
uh do you have any political ambitions
to run for president yourself someday
i i am all of 30 years old and
stockton's aged me more and more every
day so i
i know i'm deeply committed um to
winning this re-election tonight
and after i'm turned out in 2024 i'll be
34 years old so i won't be able to run
for president
um but if there is an office that makes
sense i would consider you
could seriously look at it but even not
i will continue to be a big mouth in the
loudmouth
or as dr king called it a drum major for
justice and also a drum major for the
best of what america can be
we are such an unfinished work of art
there's so much work we can do
and i'm excited about using my time on
this earth to pushing us to get there
mayor tubbs we can't thank you enough
for making time for us tonight um i know
we have to let you go soon but i want to
quickly ask you about your one-year-old
did you
uh take your sweet angel baby to the
polls with you today
yes it was funny because before we
walked out to vote my wife and i had a
little tussle about who could hold him
because he's like a little cherub right
you want to be seen with the cherub
but she didn't like the way we told him
so she ended up holding him
also for the rest of his life to be a
picture of him and his mom and me on the
side but no he's
he's a good reminder of why it's
important to vote and what's at stake
and why this work work is
work is worth it so this is his second
election he went with us when he was six
months old to the primary
um by the time he's 18 he'll be battle
tested and ready
um to vote and continue to make our
country what it could be
and one final question actually you
mentioned the primary can you tell me a
little bit about what it's been like for
you
to go all the way from the primary to
finally we're here on november 3rd
a lot has gone down over the what what
has that been like for you
it feels like another world and i i um i
was
my feelings were hurt i didn't win 50
with eight people in the primary i had a
little bit of an attitude
but then the next week it was coveted
time so i just snap out
of my little funk and get focused on
governing and delivering for my people
so in retrospect i'm actually thankful
for the opportunity to have to run for
office during this time
because it's made me very sensitive and
very um
in tune with what was happening in
community and also tested my medal
because during this time i had to make
unpopular decisions
i had to call for things like mask
ordinances that a lot of people didn't
like i had to
fight with our county government for
karazhak resources i had to um
do things like buy hotels for for for
individuals who are homeless as a means
of creating permanent supportive housing
but also millionaire and kova so it's
been a challenge
and i cannot wait to have one job to do
uh which is to be mayor of stockton and
not have to run and i'll be term limited
so literally my only focus would be
being mayor of stockton i'm looking
forward to that day
well mayor tubbs i know you have a busy
election night yourself ahead best of
luck to you and thank you so much for
joining us
for everyone watching please continue to
follow our coverage here on quick take
throughout the night and we'll see you
soon thanks so much